ついついコンビニとかで一番くじがあると b 紹介書が出るまで回してしまいます
肇社長ですが気づいた時には遅かったんですけどもだいぶ昔にゼルダの伝説
ゼルダの伝説の一番くじがあったみたいですけどその中の商品の一つにめちゃくちゃ
いいのがあってなんかネットとか twitter とかで見たんですけどこんなんか
開ければ一番くじも終わっているが買えなくてどうしたかっていうとアマゾンで
プレミア価格で買いました
こちらでちょっと開ける音ちゃんとか入ってやっぱ d 賞なんだ
デザイナーでフェットの一番口の d 者ですねエフェクト等というものでございまー
すこれは謎解き正解よ
こっちが宝箱キャッチファンファーレって言ってれれーんどぅ
0によく歩こう
効果音が流れるっていうものなんですけどもうちょっと上げてみました年賀けれど
もったいないけど
開けないと使えないかでよしたはいこれです2つあるんですけどもまぁちょっといい
ことあってね続けてて一定の距離話すと
何もなりません違うなんでなんで一定なければな人じゃないっていう
旧九州に急に陥ってこれで言ってるけど話すと
て音が鳴るわけですよ要するにこれ何かといいますと例えばドアとかにコテつけておき
ます壁とドアにつけてドアが開くと
維持ねこれ不具合を使ったんですよ
もう一つの方はちなみにどんなのかというと
で5
これすごいで応用できるところはないと来て今回はこのエフェクトを使ってちょっと
いろんなことをしていきたいと思いますまず普通にもう
純粋にスキッズでいろいろ遊んでいきましょうでは
よ
pandan
dare
ポセバス悪かったからどっかぱっぱーてぃまおうがばた
酸っぱいああああああ
woo
バーバーさーああああああ
奪ったのがまた興奮人間ちゃさあてから払わせ化するっておいてちょっと出てるを先制
[音楽]
ん to power
ああああああ
お疲れ様でした
えっ
[音楽]
はぁ
ます
何吸っ
放ったなぁ
んすごい car
ああああああああ
あああああ
まぼ2
うわあああああ
カメラで言って短めのどっかでくっさー
ねぷっすま普通のよっ
2倍
ちょっと言ったからってねー
マーサーのみ camera ぱ
[音楽]
あっ
すまんかい
あった
は
んあー
何とも言えないですよ manor
goo
キハ
ですかうーん
ksr 2バーバー
ana ああああ
バーバー
うーんたーーーパパ
パーンたーーーばぁばそこさーん
[音楽]
ああああああああ
はっはっは
4位
これは